good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
[Music]
you've heard about the nazi book
burnings the bands the censorship
the oppressions of the third reich
you've seen the images black and white
footage of chanting believers
flames flying high they're images of
evil and you know how they end
but few people know these book burnings
largely weren't some big government
crackdown
look closer at those dark and grainy
images you've seen
most of the participants aren't soldiers
or policemen
they're smiling laughing young people it
was a fun time for them
they were on the right side of history
they thought they were part of something
bigger than themselves
they didn't know that what they were a
part of would swallow every one of them
by the time it was finished
few people remember that the book
burnings of the german 1930s were led by
student activists
who started with their own campus
libraries they didn't want the books
that challenged their delegate
minds a lot triggered our young little
nazis
when they ran out of campus libraries
they came for the independent bookstores
the government happy to help only came
in later
does this sound familiar they were the
vanguard
but the people in power did agree with
them if you were reading the new york
times on april 7th 1933
and that friday morning you would flip
to page 11 you would see
condensed in a few short paragraphs the
news that the nazi government had banned
the parts of the old testament
they didn't like they were making moves
to consolidate
the protestant churches into a new state
version of christianity
complete with its own saints they were
starting a new religion you see
just below that a wire from the new york
times berlin correspondent
told of a monarchist newspaper warning
that the catholic church
would not be so easily rolled and german
catholics would not abide the pope being
replaced
with some government minister so the
nazi government banned catholic
publications in the country
mobs did most of the government's work
for them sometimes they dressed up in
little uniforms first
in their dress and their tactics they
might stir recollections among
a few people in portland who remember
the saga of the independent bookstore
powell's books
which this winter had the audacity to
feature reporter andy knows writing
on the violence besetting their city at
the hands of black-clad
thugs the thugs threatened them for this
and the bookstore was afraid
no one in portland was going to stand up
for them if you lived in portland
would you count on the police to protect
you the politicians make sure they can't
the bookstore was protested covered in
signs forced to shut its doors early and
threatened
so the owners folded to the mob andy noe
who has been on this program
wouldn't see his books on their shelves
after all if customers wanted it they
could go online
just this week noah was nearly beaten to
death again
with zero action taken or promised by
local authorities who have acquiesced to
the mob running their city
we always pretend to learn from our
history and assume we are somehow
more enlightened than our ancestors that
they were evil
but we are fit to make our own rules our
own history to ban ideas
to ban george washington and abraham
lincoln and tom sawyer and huck finn
and dr seuss and those catholic
teachings that inconvenience us
we're experts now we've got this as
george mcdonald wrote the one principle
of hell
is i am my own the first thing tyrants
do when they're in charge is banned
speech
but not just any speech they ban the
speech that threatens them
often if a group that threatens them is
powerful or influential
they'll give them a chance to follow the
rules do the good
thing there's that right side of history
rhetoric again
the nazis wanted the church to stick to
its own business
don't speak out on politics don't meddle
in things you don't understand
stay behind your pulpit priest let the
eugenicist scientists
the modern men deal with the things that
matter leave it to the experts
and if the leaders of the country wanted
to openly reject
church teachings who are you to speak up
in the book of ecclesiastes we read the
warning
what has been will be again what has
been done will be done again
there is nothing new under the sun every
day we see the signs of a new fanaticism
in our country
and the eagerness to join with the new
movement
some of the daily devotions are absurd
and laughable like msnbc's religious
adherence to wearing two masks while you
jog
as a sign of your loyalty to the woke
regime some of the devotions are far
more troubling
like the banning of books exposing the
trans agenda's real harm for troubled
children
or reporters staring at a human
catastrophe on our border where humans
are controlled and killed and raped
by sprawling criminal gangs who turn
around to the tv cameras
to lie to you about it and tell you
they're just children being victimized
by the mean american policemen the
ruling class doesn't need to do
everything itself they can pick at the
peripherals
and nod in agreement while the mobs and
the students
the corrupt corporate press and the tech
oligarchs get their hands dirty
you're not allowed to talk about the
wuhan lab leak until you are
the press and the oligarch say we've
always been at war with east asia
the words of gk chesterton apply here a
dead thing
can go with the stream but only a living
thing can go against it
and where those stubborn americans who
are alive and awake
go against the current refusing to
submit to this new woke religion or its
indulgences
the leftist oligarchs will use their
power both government and corporate to
crush them
so they'll teach the new race hate to
our students our soldiers and our
diplomats
they'll mock the vatican for calling for
clergy to hold sin to account for the
sake of the sinner
by flying the rainbow flag from their
embassy they'll tell the hispanic and
indigenous people suffering in guatemala
that their problems stem from their
racism against african-americans
and their anti-lgbt bias maybe google
and facebook
can sponsor a campaign to support it all
do you see what's going on here do you
understand
the underlying threat we are a free
people because we understand
where our rights come from as george
washington said in his farewell address
reason and experience both forbid us to
expect that national morality can
prevail an exclusion
of religious principle this isn't
incidental
it's essential without faith we collapse
as a people and as a country
a left comes for religious americans not
because they want to abolish religion
but because they want to replace it with
race politics
with scientism and with their marxist
fascist agenda
that would pile the bibles high and turn
them into ash
and yet the light shines in the darkness
and the darkness has not overcome it it
won't
it can't and we as free americans will
make sure it never does
i'm ben dominic and this is the american
crisis
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else